Hashing.
Today we're going to do some
amazing stuff with hashing.
And, really,
this is such neat stuff,
it's amazing.
We're going to start by
addressing a fundamental
weakness of hashing.
And that is that for any choice
of hash function
There exists a bad set of keys
that all hash to the same slot.
OK.
So you pick a hash function.
We looked at some that seem to
work well in practice,
that are easy to put into your
code.
But whichever one you pick,
there's always some bad set of
keys.
So you can imagine,
just to drive this point home a
little bit.
Imagine that you're building a
compiler for a customer and you
have a symbol table in your
compiler and one of the things
that the customer is demanding
is that compilations go fast.
They don't want to sit around
waiting for compilations.
And you have a competitor who's
also building a compiler and
they're going to test the
compiler, both of your compilers
and sort of have a run-off.
And one of the things in the
test that they're going to allow
you to do is not only will the
customer run his own benchmarks,
but he'll let you make up
benchmarks for the other
program, for your competitor.
And your competitor gets to
make up benchmarks for you.
So and not only that,
but you're actually sharing
code.
So you get to look at what the
competitor is actually doing and
what hash function they're
actually using.
So it's pretty clear that in
this circumstance,
you have an adversary who is
going to look at whatever hash
function you have and figure out
OK, what's a set of variable
names and so forth that are
going to all hash to the same
slot so that essentially you're
just chasing through a linked
list whenever it comes to
looking something up.
Slowing down your program
enormously compared to if in
fact they got distributed nicely
across the hash table which is,
what after all,
you have a hash table in there
to do in the first place.
And so the question is,
how do you defeat this
adversary?
And the answer is one word.
One word.
How do you achieve?
How do you defeat any adversary
in this class?
Randomness.
OK.
You make it so that he can't
guess.
And the idea is that you choose
a hash function at random.
Independent.
So he can look at the code,
but when it actually runs,
it's going to use a random hash
function that he has no way of
predicting what the hash
function is that will actually
be used.
OK.
So that's the game and that way
he can provide an input,
but he can't provide an input
that's guaranteed to force you
to run slowly.
You might get unlucky in your
choice of hash function,
but it's not going to be
because of the adversary.
So the idea is to choose a hash
function --
-- at random,
independently from the keys
that you're, that are going to
be fed to it.
So even if your adversary can
see your code,
he can't tell which hash
function is going to be actually
used at run time.
Doesn't get to see the output
of the random numbers.
And so it turns out you can
make this scheme work and the
name of the scheme is universal
hashing, OK, is one way of
making this scheme work.
So let's do some math.
So let U be a universe of keys.
And let H be a finite
collection --
-- of hash functions --
-- mapping U to what are going
to be the slots in our hash
table.
OK.
So we just have H as some
finite collection.
We say that H is universal --
-- if for all pairs of the
keys, distinct keys --
-- so the keys are distinct,
the following is true.
So if the set of keys,
if for any pair of keys I pick,
the number of hash functions
that hash those two keys to the
same place is a one over m
fraction of the total set of
keys.
So let m just,
so to view that,
another way of viewing that is
if H is chosen randomly --
-- from the set of keys H,
the probability of collision
between x and y is what?
What's the probability if the
fraction of hash functions,
OK, if the number of hash
functions is H over m,
what's the probability of a
collision between x and y?
If I pick a hash function at
random.
So I pick a hash function at
random, what's the odds they
collide?
One over m.
Now let's draw a picture for
that, help people see that
that's in fact the case.
So imagine this is our set of
all hash functions.
OK.
And then if I pick a particular
x and y, let's say that this is
the set of hash functions such
that H of x is equal to H of y.
And so what we're saying is
that the cardinality of that set
is one over m times the
cardinality of H.
So if I throw a dart and pick
one hash function at random,
the odds are one in m that the
hash function falls into this
particular set.
And of course,
this has to be true of every x
and y that I can pick.
Of course, it will be a
different set,
a different x and y will
somehow map the hash functions
differently, but the odds that
for any x and y that I pick,
the odds that if I have a
random hash function,
it hashes it to the same place,
is one over m.
Now this is a little bit hard
sometimes for people to get
their head around because we're
used to thinking of perhaps
picking keys at random or
something.
OK, that's not what's going on
here.
We're picking hash functions at
random.
So our probability space is
defined over the hash functions,
not over the keys.
And this has to be true now for
any particular two keys that I
pick that are distinct.
That the places that they hash,
this set of hash functions,
I mean this is like a marvelous
property if you think about it.
OK, that you can actually find
ones where no matter what two
elements I pick,
the odds are exactly one in m
that a random hash function from
this set is going to hash them
to the same place.
So very neat.
Very, very neat property and
we'll see the mathematics
associated with this is very
cool.
So our theorem is that if we
choose h randomly from the set
of hash functions H,
and then we suppose we're
hashing n keys into m slots in
Table T --
-- then for given key x --
-- the expected number of
collisions with x --
-- is less than n over m.
And who remembers what we call
n over m?
Alpha, which is the,
what's the term that we use
there?
Load factor.
The load factor of the table.
OK, load factor alpha.
So the average number of keys
per slot is the load factor of
the table.
So we're saying,
so what is this theorem saying?
It's saying that in fact,
if we have one of these
universal sets of hash
functions, then things perform
exactly the way we want them to.
Things get distributed evenly.
The number of things that are
going to collide with any
particular key that I pick is
going to be n over m.
So that's a really good
property to have.
Now I haven't shown you,
the construction of U is going,
sorry, of the set of hash
functions H, that that
construction will take us a
little bit of effort.
But first I want to show you
why this is such a great
property.
Basically it's this theorem.
So let's prove this theorem.
So any questions about what the
statement of the theorem is?
So we're going to go actually
kind of fast today.
We've got a lot of good stuff
today.
So I want to make sure people
are onboard as we go through.
So if there are any questions,
make sure, you know,
statement of theorem of
whatever, best to get them out
early so that you're not
confused later on when the going
gets a little more exciting.
OK?
OK, good.
So to prove this,
let's let C sub x be the random
variable denoting the total
number of collisions --
-- of keys in T with x.
So this is a total number and
one of the techniques that you
use a lot in probabilistic
analysis of randomized
algorithms is recognizing that C
of x is in fact a sum of
indicator random variables.
If you can decompose things
into indicator random variables,
the analysis goes much more
easily than if you're left with
aggregate variables.
So here we're going to let our
indicator random variable be
little c of x.,
which is going to be one if h
of x equals h of y and 0
otherwise.
And so we can note two things.
First, what is the expectation
of C of x..
OK, if I have a process which
is picking a hash function at
random, what's the expectation
of C of x.?
One over m.
Because that's basically this
definition here.
Now in other words I pick a
hash function at random,
what's the odds that the hash
is the same?
It's one over m.
And then the other thing is,
and the reason we pick this
thing is that I can express
capital C sub x,
the random variable denoting
the total number of collisions
as being just the sum over all
the keys in the table except x
of C of x..
So for each one that would
cause me a collision,
with x, I add one and if it
wouldn't cause me a collision,
I add 0.
And that adds up all of the
collisions that I would have in
the table with x.
Is there any questions so far?
Because this is the set-up.
The set-up in most of these
things, the set-up is where most
students make mistakes and most
practicing researchers make
mistakes as well,
let me tell you.
And then once you get the
set-up right,
then working out the math is
fine, but it's often that set-up
of how do you actually translate
the situation into the math.
That's the hard part.
Once you get that right,
well, then, algebra,
we can all do algebra.
Of course, we can also all make
mistakes doing algebra,
but at least those mistakes are
much more easy to check than the
one that does the translation.
So I want to make sure people
are sort of understanding of how
that's set up.
So now we just have to use our
math skills.
So the expectation then of the
number of collisions is the
expectation of C sub x and
that's just the expectation of
just plugging the sum of y and T
minus the element x of c_xy.
So that's just definition.
And that's equal to the sum of
y and T minus x of expectation
of c_xy.
So why is that?
Yeah, that's linearity.
Linearity of expectation,
doesn't require independence.
It's true of all random
variables.
And that's equal to,
and now the math gets easier.
So what is that?
One over m.
That makes the summation easy
to evaluate.
That's just n minus one over m.
So fairly simple analysis and
shows you why we would love to
have one of these sets of
universal hash functions because
if you have them,
then they behave exactly the
way you would want it to behave.
And you defeat your adversary
by just picking up the hash
function at random.
There's nothing he can do.
Or she.
OK, any questions about that
proof?
OK, now we get into the fun
math.
Constructing one of these
babies.
OK.
This is not the only
construction.
This is a construction of a
classic universal hash function.
And there are other
constructions in the literature
and I think there's one on the
practice quiz.
So let's see.
So this one works when m is
prime.
So it works when the set of
slots is a prime number.
Number of slots is a prime
number.
So the idea here is we're going
to decompose any key k in our
universe into r plus 1 digits.
So k, we're going to look at as
being a k 0, k one,
k_r where 0 is less than or
equal to k sub I,
is less than or equal to m
minus one.
So the idea is in some sense
we're looking at what the
representation would be of k
base m.
So if it were base two,
it would be just one bit at a
time.
These would just be the bits.
I'm not going to do base two.
We're going to do base min
general and so each of these
represents one of the digits.
And the way I've done it is
I've done low order digit first.
It actually doesn't matter.
We're not actually going to
care really about what the order
is, but basically we're just
looking at busting it into a
twofold represented by each of
those digits.
So one algorithm for computing
this out of k is take the
remainder mod m.
That's the low order one.
OK, take what's left.
Take the remainder of that mod
m.
Take whatever's left,
etc.
So you're familiar with the
conversion to a base
representation.
That's exactly how we're
getting this representation.
So we treat,
this is just a question of
taking the data that we've got
and treating it as an r plus one
base m number.
And now we invoke our
randomized strategy.
The randomized strategy is
going to be able to have a class
of hash functions that's
dependent essentially on random
numbers.
And the random numbers we're
going to pick is we're going to
pick an a at random --
-- which we're also going to
look at as a base mnumber.
For each a_i is chosen randomly
--
-- from --
-- 0 to m minus one.
So one of our,
it's a random if you will,
it's a random base mdigit.
Random base m digit.
So each one of these is picked
at random.
And for each one we,
possible value of A,
we're going to get a different
hash function.
So we're going to index our
hash functions by this random
number.
So this is where the randomness
is going to come in.
Everybody with me?
And here's the hash function.
So what we do is we dot product
this vector with this vector and
take the result,
mod m.
So each digit of k of our key
gets multiplied by a random
other digit.
We add all those up and we take
that mod m.
So that's a dot product
operator.
And this is what we're going to
show is universal,
that this set of h sub a,
where I look over that whole
set.
So one of the things we need to
know is how big is the set of
hash functions here.
So how big is this set of hash
functions?
How many different hash
functions do I have in this set?
It's basic 6.042 material.
It's basically how many vectors
of length r plus one where each
element of the vector is a
number of 0 to m minus one,
has m different values.
So how many?
m minus one to the r.
No.
Close.
It's up there.
It's a big number.
m to the r plus one.
Good.
It's m, so the size of H is
equal to m to the r plus one.
So we're going to want to
remember that.
OK, so let's just understand
why that is.
I have m choices for the first
value of A.
m for the second,
etc.
m for the r th.
And since there are plus one
things here, for each choice
here, I have this many same
number of choices here,
so it's a product.
OK, so this is the product rule
in counting.
So if you haven't reviewed your
6.042 notes for counting,
this is going to be a good idea
to go back and review that
because we're doing stuff of
that nature.
This is just the product rule.
Good.
So then the theorem we want to
prove is that H is universal.
And this is going to involve a
little bit of number theory,
so it gets kind of interesting.
And it's a non-trivial proof,
so this is where if there's any
questions as I'm going along,
please ask because the argument
is not as simple as other
arguments we've seen so far.
OK, not the ones we've seen so
far have been simple,
but this is definitely a more
involved mathematical argument.
So here's a proof.
So let's let,
so we have two keys.
What are we trying to show if
it's universal,
that if I pick any two keys,
the number of hash functions
for which they hash to the same
thing is the size of set of hash
functions divided by m.
OK, so I'm going to look at two
keys.
So let's pick two keys
arbitrarily.
So x, and we'll decompose it
into our base r representation
and y, y_0, y_1 --
So these are two distinct keys.
So if these are two distinct
keys, so they're different,
then this base representation
has the property that they've
got to differ somewhere.
Right?
OK, they differ in at least one
digit.
OK, and this is where most
people get lost because I'm
going to make a simplification.
They could differ in any one of
these digits.
I'm going to say they differ in
position 0 because it doesn't
matter which one I do,
the math is the same,
but it'll make it so that if I
pick some said they differ in
some position i,
I would have to be taking
summations as you'll see over
the elements that are not i,
and that's complicated.
If I do it in position 0,
then I can just sum for the
rest of them.
So the math is going to be
identical if I were to do it for
any position because it's
symmetric.
All the digits are symmetric.
So let's say they differ in
position 0, but the same
argument is going to be true if
they differed in some other
position.
So let's say,
so we're saying without loss of
generality.
So that's without loss of
Position 0.
Because all the positions are
symmetric here.
And so, now we need to ask the
question for how many --
-- hash functions in our
universal, purportedly universal
set do x and y collide?
OK, we've got to count them up.
So how often do they collide?
This is where we're going to
pull out some heavy duty number
theory.
So we must have,
if they collide --
-- that h sub a of x is equal
to h sub a of y.
That's what it means for them
to collide.
So that implies that the sum of
i equal 0 to r of a sub i x sub
i is equal to the sum of i
equals 0 to r of a sub i y sub i
mod m.
Actually this is congruent mod
m.
So congruence for those people
who haven't seen much number
theory, is basically the way of
essentially, rather than having
to say mod everywhere in here
and mod everywhere in here,
we just at the end say OK,
do a mod at the end.
Everything is being done mod,
module m.
And then typically we use a
congruence sign.
OK, there's a more mathematical
definition but this will work
for us engineers.
OK, so everybody with me so
far?
This is just applying the
definition.
So that implies that the sum of
i equals 0 to r of a i x i minus
y i is congruent to zeros mod m.
OK, just threw it on the other
side and applied the
distributive law.
Now what I'm going to do is
pull out the 0-th position
because that's the one that I
care about.
And this is where it saves me
on the math, compared to if I
didn't say that it was 0.
I'd have to pull out x_i.
It wouldn't matter,
but it just would make the math
a little bit cruftier
OK, so now we've just pulled
out one term.
That implies that a_0 x_0 minus
y_0 is congruent to minus --
-- mod m.
Now remember that when I have a
minus number mod m,
I just map it into whatever,
into that range from 0 to m
minus one.
So for example,
minus five mod seven is two.
So if any of these things are
negative, we simply translate
them into by adding multiples of
mbecause adding multiples of m
doesn't affect the congruence.
OK.
And now for the next step,
we need to use a number theory
fact.
So let's pull out our number
theory --
-- textbook and take a little
digression
So this comes from the theory
of finite fields.
So for people who are
knowledgeable,
that's where you're plugging
your knowledge in.
If you're not knowledgeable,
this is a great area of math to
learn about.
So here's the fact.
So let m be prime.
Then for any z,
little z element of z sub m,
and z sub m is the integers mod
m.
So this is essentially numbers
from 0 to m minus one with all
the operations,
times, minus,
plus, etc., defined on that
such that if you end up outside
of the range of 0 to m minus
one, you re-normalize by
subtracting or adding multiples
of m to get back within the
range from 0 to m minus one.
So it's the standard thing of
just doing things module m.
So for any z such that z is not
congruent to 0,
there exists a unique z inverse
in z sub m, such that if I
multiply z times the inverse,
it produces something congruent
to one mod m.
So for any number it says,
I can find another number that
when multiplied by it gives me
one.
So let's just do an example for
m equals seven.
So here we have,
we'll make a little table.
So z is not equal to 0,
so I just write down the other
numbers.
And let's figure out what z
inverse is.
So what's the inverse of one?
What number when multiplied by
one gives me one?
One.
Good.
How about two?
What number when I multiply it
by two gives me one?
Four.
Because two times four is eight
and eight is congruent to one
mod seven.
So I've re-normalized it.
What about three?
Five.
Good.
Three times five is 15.
That's congruent to one mod
seven because 15 divided by
seven is two remainder of one.
So that's the key thing.
What about four?
Two.
Five? Three. And six.
Yeah.
Six.
Yeah, six it turns out.
OK, six times six is 36.
OK, mod seven.
Basically subtract off the 35,
gives m one.
So people have observed some
interesting facts that if one
number's an inverse of another,
then that other is an inverse
of the one.
So that's actually one of these
things that you prove when you
do group theory and field theory
and so forth.
There are all sorts of other
great properties of this kind of
math.
But the main thing is,
and this turns out not to be
true if m is not a prime.
So can somebody think of,
imagine we're doing something
mod 10.
Can somebody think of a number
that doesn't have an inverse mod
10?
Yeah.
Two.
Another one is five.
OK, it turns out the divisors
in fact actually,
more generally,
something that is not
relatively prime,
meaning that it has no common
factors, the GCD is not one
between that number and the
modulus.
OK, those numbers do not have
an inverse mod m.
OK, but if it's prime,
every number is relatively
prime to the modulus.
And that's the property that
we're taking advantage of.
So this is our fact and so,
in this case what I'm after is
I want to divide by x_0 minus
y_0.
That's what I want to do at
this point.
But I can't do that if x_0,
first of all,
if m isn't prime,
I can't necessarily do that.
I might be able to,
but I can't necessarily.
But if m is prime,
I can definitely divide by x_0
minus y_0.
I can find that inverse.
And the other thing I have to
do is make sure x_0 minus y_0 is
not 0.
OK, it would be 0 if these two
were equal, but our supposition
was they weren't equal.
And once again,
just bringing it back to the
without loss of generality,
if it were some other position
that we were off,
I would be doing exactly the
same thing with that position.
So now we're going to be able
to divide.
So we continue with our --
-- continue with our proof.
So since x_0 is not equal to
y_0, there exists an inverse for
x_0 minus y_0.
And that implies,
just continue on from over
there, that a_0 is congruent
therefore to minus the sum of i
equal one to r of a_i,
x_i minus y_i times x_0 minus
y_0 inverse.
So let's just go back to the
beginning of our proof and see
what we've derived.
If we're saying we have two
distinct keys,
and we've picked all of these
a_i randomly,
and we're saying that these two
distinct keys hash to the same
place.
If they hash to the same place,
it says that a_0 essentially
had to have a particular value
as a function of the other a_i.
Because in other words,
once I've picked each of these
a_i from one to r,
if I did them in that order,
for example,
then I don't have a choice for
how I pick a_0 to make it
collide.
Exactly one value allows it to
collide, namely the value of a_0
given by this.
If I picked a different value
of a_0, they wouldn't collide.
So let m write that down.
Thus, while you think about it
So for any choice of these a_i,
there's exactly one of the
impossible choices of a_0 that
cause a collision.
And for all the other choices I
might make of a_0,
there's n collision.
So essentially I don't have,
if they're going to collide,
I've reduced essentially the
number of degrees of freedom of
my randomness by a factor of m.
So if I count up the number of
h_a's that cause x and y to
collide, that's equal to,
well, there's m choices,
just using the product rule
again.
There's m choices for a_1 times
m choices for a_2,
up to m choices for a_r and
then only one choice for a_0.
So this is choices for a_1,
a_2, a_r and only one choice
for a_0 if they're going to
collide.
If they're not going to
collide, I've got more choices
for a_0.
But if I want them to collide,
there's only one value I can
pick, namely this value.
That's the only value for which
I will pick.
And that's equal to m to the r,
which is just the size of H
divided by m.
And that completes the proof.
So there are other universal
constructions,
but this is a particularly
elegant one.
So the point is that I have m
plus one, sorry,
r plus one degrees of freedom
where each degree of freedom I
have m choices.
But if I want them to collide,
once I've picked any of the,
once I've picked r of those
possible choices,
the last one is forced if I
want it to collide.
So therefore,
the set of functions for which
it collides is only one in m.
A very slick construction.
Very slick.
OK.
Everybody with me here?
Didn't lose too many people?
Yeah, question.
Well, part of it is,
actually this is a quite common
type of thing to be doing
actually.
If you take a class,
so we have follow on classes in
cryptography and so forth,
and this kind of thing of
taking dot products,
modulo m and also Galois fields
which are particularly simple
finite fields and things like
that, people play with these all
the time.
So Galois fields are like using
exor's as your,
same sort of thing as this
except base two.
And so there's a lot of study
of this sort of thing.
So people understand these kind
of properties.
But yeah, it's like what's the
algorithm for having a brilliant
insight into algorithms?
It's like OK.
Wish I knew.
Then I'd just turn the crank.
[LAUGHTER] But if it were that
easy, I wouldn't be standing up
here today.
[LAUGHTER] Good.
OK, so now I want to take on
another topic which is also I
find, I think this is
astounding.
It's just beautiful,
beautiful mathematics and a big
impact on your ability to build
good hash functions.
Now I want to talk about
another one topic,
which is related,
which is the topic of perfect
hashing.
So everything we've done so far
does expected time performance.
Hashing is good in the expected
sense.
A perfect hashing addresses the
following questions.
Suppose that I gave you a set
of keys, and I said just build
me a static table so I can look
up whether the key is in the
table with worst case time.
Good worst case time.
So I have a fixed set of keys.
They might be something like
for example, the hundred most
common or thousand most common
words in English.
And when I get a word I want to
check quickly in this table,
is the word that I've got one
of the most common words in
English.
I would like to do that not
with expected performance,
but guaranteed worst case
performance.
Is there a way of building it
so that I can find this quickly?
So the problem is given n keys
--
-- construct a static hash
table.
In other words,
no insertion and deletion.
We're just going to put the
elements in there.
A size --
-- m equal Order n.
So I don't want it to be a huge
table.
I want it to be a table that is
the size of my keys.
Table of size m equals Order n,
such that search takes O(1)
time in the worst case.
So there's no place in the
table where I'm going to have,
I know in the average case,
that's not hard to do.
But in the worst case,
I want to make sure that
there's no particular spot where
the number of keys piles up to
be a large number.
OK, in no spot should that
happen.
Every single search I do should
take Order one time.
There shouldn't be any
statistical variation in terms
of how long it takes me to get
something.
Does everybody understand what
the puzzle is?
So this is a great,
because this actually ends up
having a lot of uses.
You know, you want to build a
table for something and you know
what the values are that you're
going look up in it.
But you don't want to spend a
lot of space on it and so forth.
So the idea here is actually
going to be to use a two-level
scheme.
So the idea is we're going to
use a two-level scheme with
universal hashing at both
levels.
So the idea is we're going to
hash, we're going to have a hash
table, we're going to hash into
slots, but rather than using
chaining, we're going to have
another hash table there.
We're going to do a second hash
into the second hash table.
And the idea is that we're
going to do it in such a way
that we have no collisions at
level two.
So we may have collisions at
level one.
We'll take anything that
collides at level one and put
them into a hash table and then
our second level hash table,
but that hash table,
no collisions.
Boom.
We're just going to hash right
in there.
And it'll just go boom to its
thing.
So let's draw a picture of this
to illustrate the scheme.
OK, so we have --
-- 0 one, let's say six,
m minus one.
So here's our hash table.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to use universal
hashing at the first level,
OK.
So we find a universal hash
function.
We pick a hash function at
random.
And what we'll do is we'll hash
into that level.
And then what we'll do is we'll
keep track of two things.
One is what the size of the
hash table is at the next level.
So in this case,
the size of the hash table will
only use the number of slots.
There's going to be four.
And we're also going to keep a
separate hash key for the second
level.
So each slot will have its own
hash function for the second
level.
So for example,
this one might have a key of 31
that is a random number.
The a's here.
a's up there.
There we go,
So that's going to be the basis
of my hash function,
the key with which I'm going to
hash.
This one say has 86.
And let's say that this,
and then we have a pointer to
the hash table.
This is say S_1.
And it's got four slots and we
stored up 14 and 27.
And these two slots are empty.
And this one for example,
had what?
Two nines.
So the idea here is that in
this case if we look over all
our top level hash function,
which I'll just call H,
has that H of 14 is equal to H
of 27 is equal to one.
Because we're in slot one.
OK, so these two both hash to
the same slot in the level one
hash table.
This is level one.
And this is level two over
here.
So level one hashing,
14 and 27 collided.
They went into the same slot
here.
But at level two,
they got hashed to different
places and the hash function I
use is going to be indexed by
whatever the random numbers are
that I chose and found for those
and I'll show you how we find
those.
We have then h of 31 of 14 is
equal to one h of 31 of 27 is
equal to two.
For level two.
So I go, hash in here,
find the, use this as the basis
of my hash function to hash into
whatever table I've got here.
And so, if there are no,
if I can guarantee that there
are no collisions at level two,
this is going to cost me Order
one time in the worst case to
look something up.
How do I look it up?
Take the value.
I apply h to it.
That takes me to some slot.
Then I look to see what the key
is for this hash function.
I apply that hash function and
that takes me to another slot.
Then I go there.
And that took me basically two
applications of hash functions
plus some look-up,
plus who knows what minor
amount of bookkeeping.
So the reason we're going to
have no collisions at this level
is the following.
If they're n sub i items that
hash to a level one slot i,
then we're going to use m sub
i, which is equal to n sub i
squared slots in the level two
hash table.
OK, so I should have mentioned
here this is going to be m sub
i, the size of the hash table
and this is going to be my a sub
i essentially.
So I'm going to use,
so basically I'm going to hash
n sub i things into n sub i
squared locations here.
So this is going to be
incredibly sparse.
OK, it's going to be quadratic
in size.
And so what I'm going to show
is that under those
circumstances,
it's easy for me to find hash
functions such that there are n
collisions.
That's the name of the game.
Figure out how can I make these
hash functions so that there are
no collisions.
So that's why I draw this with
so few elements here.
So here for example,
I have two elements and I have
a hash table size four here.
I have three elements.
I need a hash table size nine.
OK, if there are a hundred
elements, I need a hash table
size 10,000.
I'm not going to pick something
so there's likely that there's
anything of that size.
And then the fact that this
actually works and gives us all
the properties that we want,
that's part of the analysis.
So does everybody see that this
takes Order one worst case time
and what the basic structure of
it is?
These things,
by the way, are not in this
case prime.
I could always pick primes that
were close to this.
I didn't do that in this case.
Or I could use a universal hash
function that in fact would work
for things other than primes.
But I didn't do that for this
example.
We all ready for analysis?
OK, let's do some analysis
then.
And this is really pretty
analysis.
Partly as you'll see because
we've already done some of this
analysis.
So the trick is analyzing level
two.
That's the main thing that I
want to analyze,
to show that I can find hash
functions here that are going
to, when I map them into,
very sparsely,
into these arrays here,
that in fact,
such hash functions exist and I
can compute them in advance.
So that I have a good way of
storing those.
So here's the theorem we're
going to use.
My hash and keys into m equals
n squared slots using a random
hash function in a universal set
H.
Then the expected number of
collisions is less than one
half.
OK.
The expected number of
collisions I don't expect there
to be even one collision.
I expect there to be less than
half a collision on average.
And so, let's prove this,
so that the probability that
two given keys collide under h
is what?
What's the probability that two
given keys collide under h when
h is chosen randomly from the
universal set?
One over m.
Right?
That's the definition,
right, of, which is in this
case equal to one over n
squared.
So now how many keys,
how many pairs of keys do I
have in this table?
How many keys could possibly
collide with each other?
OK.
So that's basically just
looking at how many different
pairs of keys do I have to
evaluate this for.
So that's n choose two pairs of
keys.
n choose two pairs of keys.
So therefore,
the expected number of
collisions is while for each of
these n, not n over two.
n choose two pairs of keys.
The probability that it
collides is one in n squared.
So that's equal to n times n
minus one over two,
if you remember your formula,
times one in n squared.
And that's less than a half.
So for every pair of keys,
so those of you who remember
from 6.042 the birthday paradox,
this is related to the birthday
paradox a little bit.
But here I basically have a
large set, and I'm looking at
all pairs, but my set is
sufficiently big that the odds
that I get a collision is
relatively small.
If I start increasing it beyond
the square root of m,
OK, the number of elements,
it starts getting bigger in the
square root of m then the odds
of a collision go up
dramatically as you know from
the birthday paradox.
But if I'm less than,
if I'm really sparse in there,
I don't get collisions.
Or at least I get a relatively
small number expected.
Now I want to remind you of
something which actually in the
past I have just assumed,
but I want to actually go
through it briefly.
It's Markov's inequality.
So who remembers Markov's
inequality?
Don't everybody raise their
hand at once.
So Markov's inequality says the
following.
This is one of these great
probability facts.
For random variable x which is
bounded below by 0,
says the probability that x is
bigger than, greater than or
equal to any given value T is
less than or equal to the
expectation of x divided by T.
It's a great fact.
Doesn't happen if x isn't bound
below by 0.
But it's a great fact.
It allows me to relate the
probability of an event to its
expectation.
And the idea is in general that
if the expectation is going to
be small, then I can't have a
high probability that the value
of the random variable is large.
It doesn't make sense.
How could you have a high
probability that it's a million
when my expectation is one or in
this case we're going to apply
it when the expectation is a
half?
Couldn't happen.
And the proof follows just
directly on the definition of
expectation, and so I'mdoing
this for a discrete random
variable.
So the expectation by
definition is just the sum from
little x goes to 0 to infinity
of x times the probability that
my random variable takes on the
value x.
That's the definition.
And now it's just a question of
doing like the coarsest
approximation you can imagine.
First of all,
let me just simply throw away
all small terms that can be
greater to or equal to x equals
T to infinity of x times the
probability that x is equal to
little x.
So just throw away all the low
order terms.
Now what I'm going to do is
replace every one of these terms
is lower bounded by the value x
equals T.
So that's just the summation of
x equals T to infinity of T
times the probability that x
equals x.
OK.
Over x going from T larger.
Because these are only bigger
values.
And that's just equal then to
T, because I can pull that out,
and the summation of x equals T
to infinity of the probability
that x equals x is just the
probability that x is greater
than or equal to T.
And that's done because I just
divide by T.
So that's Markov's inequality.
Really dumb.
Really simple.
There are much stronger things
like Chebyshev bounds and
Chernoff bounds and things of
that nature.
But Markov's is like
unbelievably simple and useful.
So we're going to just apply
that as a corollary.
So the probability now of no
collisions, when I hash n keys
into n squared slots using a
universal hash function,
I claim is the probability of
no collisions is greater than or
equal to a half.
So I pick a hash function at
random.
What are the odds that I got no
collisions when I hashed those n
keys into n squared slots?
Answer.
Probability is I have no
collisions is at least a half.
Half the time I'm guaranteed
that there won't be a collision.
And the proof,
pretty simple.
The probability of no
collisions is the same as the
probability as,
sorry, is one minus the
probability that I have at most
one collision.
So the odds that I have at
least one collision,
the odds that I have at least
one collision,
probability greater than or
equal to one collision is less
than or equal to,
now I just apply Markov's
inequality with this.
So it's just the expected
number of collisions --
-- divided by one.
And that is by Markov's
inequality less than,
by definition,
excuse me, of expected number
of collisions,
which we've already shown,
is less than a half.
So the probability of at least
one collision is less than a
half.
The probability of 0 collisions
is at least a half.
So we're done here.
So to find a good level to hash
function is easy.
I just test a few at random.
Most of them out there,
OK, half of them,
at least half of them are going
to work.
So this is in some sense,
if you think about it,
a randomized construction,
because I can't tell you which
one it's going to be.
It's non-constructive in that
sense, but it's a randomized
construction.
But they have to exist because
most of them out there have this
good property.
So I'mgoing to be able to find
for each one of these,
I just test a few at random,
and I find one.
Test a few at random,
find one, etc.
Fill in my table there.
Because all that is
pre-computation.
And I'mgoing to find them
because the odds are good that
one exists.
So --
-- we just test a few at random.
And we'll find one quickly --
-- since at least half will
work.
I just want to show that there
exists good ones.
All I have to prove is that at
least one works for each of
these cases.
In fact, I've shown that
there's a huge number that will
work.
Half of them will work.
But to show it exists,
I would just have to show that
the probability was greater than
0.
So to finish up,
we need to still analyze the
storage because I promised in my
theorem that the table would be
of size order n.
And yet now I've said there's
all of these quadratic-sized
slots here.
So I'mgoing to show that that's
order n.
So for level one,
that's easy.
We'll just choose the number of
slots to be equal to the number
of keys.
And that way the storage at
level one is just order n.
And now let's let n sub i be
the random variable for the
number of keys --
-- that hash to slot i in T.
OK, so n sub i is just what
we've called it.
Number of elements that slot
there.
And we're going to use m sub i
equals n sub i squared slots in
each level two table S sub i.
So the expected total storage --
-- is just n for level one,
order n if you want,
but basically n slots for level
one plus the expected value,
whatever I expect the sum of i
equals 0 to m minus one of theta
of n sub i squared to be.
Because I basically have to add
up the square for every element
that applies here,
the square of what's in there.
Who recognizes this summation?
Where have we seen that before?
Who attends recitation?
Where have we seen this before?
What's the --
We're summing the expected
value of a bunch of --
Yeah, what was that algorithm?
We did the sorting algorithm,
right?
What was the sorting algorithm
for which this was an important
thing to evaluate?
Don't everybody shout it out at
once.
What was that sorting algorithm
called?
Bucket sort.
Good.
Yeah.
We showed that the sum of the
squares of random variables when
they're falling randomly into n
bins is order n.
Right?
And you can also out of this
get a, as we did before,
get a probability bound.
What's the probability that
it's more than a certain amount
times n using Markov's
inequality.
But this is the key thing is
we've seen this analysis.
OK, we used it there in time,
so there's a little bit,
but that's one of the reasons
we study sorting at the
beginning of the term is because
the techniques of sorting,
they just propagate into all
these other areas of analysis.
You see a lot of the same kinds
of things.
And so now that you know bucket
sort clearly so well,
now you know that this without
having to do any extra work.
So you might want to go back
and review your bucket sort
analysis, because it's applied
now.
Same analysis.
Two places.
OK.
Good recitation this Friday,
which will be a quiz review and
we have a quiz next,
there's no class on Monday,
but we have a quiz on next
Wednesday.
OK, so good luck everybody on
the quiz.
Make sure you get plenty of
sleep.